[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
associate editor for politics at the
Delhi Telegraph Christopher hope and the
columnist and broadcaster Steve Richards
who are with us from now until just
before midnight and welcome to both of
you so those front pages let's start
with the Daily Telegraph it carries a
warning for prime minister Liz truss
from the IMF with the headline reverse
tax cuts
Market turmoil requires tough action
from the bank of England his chief
Economist warns uh reads the front of
the financial times
and the sun covers mortgage fears over
inflation Rises their headline bricking
it
house price warning as loan rates rise
sharply reads the front of the times
the front of the Metro carries comments
made by the labor leaders Dharma at the
Party Conference today don't forgive
while tomorrow's Guardian reads A labor
moment starmer sets out his plan for a
return to power
the mirror also looks at this story the
headline Britain will get its future
back
tomorrow's Express says covid and flu
viruses could wreak havoc on the Health
Service this winter it's headlined twin
demick alert go get your Jabs and the
front of the Daily Mail claims to have
obtained a photo they say shows one of
the men convicted of the murder of
Stephen Lawrence using a mobile phone in
prison
a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages while
you watch our guests so let's return to
them we're joined by Christopher hope
and Steve Richards welcome to both of
you another set of you know markets in
turmoil economy in in shock Etc talk us
through it then uh Christopher if you
can and the front page of the Ft for
example tough action required from the
bank of England and elsewhere of course
we've heard the IMF suggesting the
government should reverse course so
where are we at
well it's all about mortgages isn't it
so it's the turmoil on the on the pound
on the on the financial markets over the
weekend and yesterday I mean the effect
of that has meant that there will be
there'll be some kind of action from the
bank of England this is the chief
Economist warning but the the concern
here that we could see
um interest rates getting up to 6.25 by
May that's a quadrupling in where they
are at the moment and given the scale of
some of the Mortgage Debt some people
have nowadays this is severely worrying
and what is happening here is the the
government through his actions last week
last Friday and subsequently is is
torching its reputation for economic
economic competence
it is trying to hold things steady
um it didn't help when Crosby got time
the chancellor went out on the
television at the weekend on on his
broadcast round and talked about them
there'll be more tax cuts coming without
any idea of of any degree of discipline
which is what the marketers want to see
they want to see cuts from the
government where will you find these
savings you can't rely on future growth
it's really worrying time
um it seems to me that the that the uh
the government doesn't it doesn't want
to talk about Market turbulence but
that's what everyone's facing and people
are feeling insecure about their family
wealth their their mortgages and that's
the worry and that once that hap once
that is embedded in people it won't be
it'll be hard to shift these are the
difficult times for conservative party
they have got time on their side they
need two years to get the economy
growing it may be that by that point
people might forgive this wobble in the
market if it is a wobble but it couldn't
well the growth mentality
um that the government was pushing on
Friday was partly to try and avoid a
deep recession you know has it has it
caused that that's the question the Sun
for example uh bricking it interest
rates to hit six percent next year
lenders pull 365 mortgage Products off
the market at the Times also talking
about house price warning as loan rates
very sharply suggesting that property
values may fall by 15 and many people um
Steve suggests actually that the you
know the housing market is one of the
great drivers of our economy
yeah this is quite extraordinary Where
We Are Tonight with this uh series of
Dramas interconnected dramas for two
basic reasons one uh the government with
its bizarre extraordinary statement
on Friday was moving in One Direction
the so-called dash for growth with
instantly little evidence that what it
was doing would lead to growth and now
the bank of England having to counter
with a sort of completely counter policy
to reassure the markets and sort of
stifle that hyper energy displayed by
quasi-quarten on Friday and then for the
second reason the Practical consequences
of this they were hailing on Friday this
great package to address the cost of
living crisis but as a result of that
package for many people with mortgages
their cost of living crisis is about to
deepen and then as Chris says you've got
the Third Kind of broader political
factor of economic incompetence within
days of what is in effect a new regime
so it is an astonishing evening once
again uh in the many interesting evening
since last Friday
well fascinating front page to the eye
and we'll come on to the Daily Telegraph
in just a moment and Christopher but
they say that the Prime Minister and
quasi-watteng ignored officials who
warned of markets turmoil suggesting
that number 10 sources have denied that
the PM had a shouting match with the
chancellor two days ago over her
reluctance to issue a statement
reassuring investors as the pound sank
and borrowing costs Rose the question of
whether they knew or not I mean you
could look to Rishi sunak and his
warnings about this which were you know
laughed off money a front page so
um did they listen and were they warned
and if so by whom
there were concerns at the top of the
treasury about the kind of caliber of it
of people who might be advising them
there was a scene to be amongst people
close to crosstalk a kind of a kind of
brown-eyed influence um amongst these
senior people we saw with the the
ousting of Sir Tom scholar who's the
most senior uh official in the treasury
and that's that was almost a message
show everybody it's my way or the
highway from the chancellor
quasi-guatang the idea of tension in
number two number 11 and number 10
nothing is new there it is new to have
it so soon in a new regime we're three
weeks into this government and that's
what's so alarming it has happened so
quickly and these concerns are on and
are making themselves known we really it
is important I think for the no country
that caused the quota and Liz trusts are
on the same hymn sheet and if there's
concerns about reassuring the market
well you know surely surely that's what
you should be doing if if the shares are
going south sorry if the in if the pound
is going south so quickly it's a big
worry I mean it's a big concern
um and one hopes that it there might be
some answers coming forward I I do think
the market wants to see some measure
some idea of where these Cuts might take
place so I'm reassuring that the the UK
is investable because that's where we
are at the moment
well meanwhile um the IMF has also
intervened uh Daily Telegraph leading on
that we are closely monitoring recent
economic developments in the UK the bit
that's been picked up by the Della
Telegraph of that headline is reverse
tax cuts the statement from the IMF the
November 23rd budget will present an
early opportunity for the UK government
to consider ways to provide support that
is more targeted and re-evaluate the tax
measures especially those that benefit
High income earners you know goodbye to
that 45 P change then Steve do you
reckon
well uh not necessarily because uh you
turn on that scale so soon after
proclaiming this great economic
Revolution would itself be damaging for
the government even if it kind of
reassured the markets in a Marginal Way
uh let's try some quasi quatane are in a
terrible bind uh a uh these kind of
Sterling crises or semi-crises what
however you want to put it traumatized
Prime Ministers and chancellors they
always do these two were in power with
the most ideological self-confident
display I've ever seen from an incoming
prime minister and Chancellor but even
that duo will be hit by the trauma of
this and it's very easy to say reverse
the tax cuts
um and they were a terrible
characteristic but once you've done it
uh to reverse it say by November would
be humiliating
but spending cuts certainly would be a
problem too okay
yeah sorry because Christopher you're
shaking your head so go for it what what
will happen in your view quickly I I I
I'm agreeing with Stephen there was no
way they can reverse these tax cuts I
mean I think the government could not
survive that technology credibility that
can't happen they are now stuck with
what they're doing it is a it is a it is
an experiment with the economy never
before seen
um if it comes off she wins the next
election if it doesn't it might bury
Toria Orthodox economic thinking for a
generation it's that high is that the
stakes are so high
well it's also fascinating to watch if
any wasn't real I suppose yeah
just very quickly because I know
the other option of spending cuts is
equally problematic for them even if
that's where they would like to go
ideologically their pledge to increase
defense spending are they going to cut
the NHS spending that as NHS needs more
what about the social care Levy that
their theorists particularly committed
to
um the idea that there are huge Acres of
spending cuts to be made as a myth as
they're about to discover if they try
and focus on that
well as I said it says there is so much
to discuss as they're not but we will
reflect on secure starman's speech to
conference after this
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview uh with me once again the
associate editor for politics at the
Delhi Telegraph Christopher hope and the
columnist and broadcaster Steve Richards
welcome back to both of you
um well the story that would have been
lead I guess uh front page of the
guardian and a number of papers to be
fair is secure stalma's big moment where
the mood we're told in Liverpool um
Steve of confidence that uh you know
labor might actually do it this time
around
yeah context done doubtedly helps you
know when you wake up on the day of your
speech and you find opinion polls giving
you huge leads that's a massive
confidence boost and it sort of changes
the way I think you are perceived as a
leader
um but that apart I thought it was an
excellent speech actually I think it was
as well judged
um and in some ways more ambitious than
those of Blair and Harold Wilson Labor's
only election winning leaders from
opposition uh pulled off when they were
leaders of the opposition it's not easy
they're very different characters he's
not a great performer like Blair
certainly was and Wilson to speak
um but I thought it was a wide-ranging
speech and I say quite ambitious
although tonally very calm and
reassuring and that's a good combination
for a labor leader well the Daily Mirror
picks up the the reassuring part of that
Britain will get its future back with
this state-owned energy pledge as well
um to hopefully cut our bills it
suggests well the Metro goes on don't
forgive and to be fair they've got a lot
to go at haven't they against the
conservatives right now
yeah yeah yes totally and the idea of
don't forgive is what uh I mean and it's
very important to to labor that the
voters don't forgive or forget what the
what's happening and the concern that's
being generated but by these government
policies I was in the hall um maybe like
Steve was what in Liverpool today I
thought that it was okay I thought that
the big the big seller was this Great
British Energy company
um if Jeremy corbyn had announced that
he may be criticized by the moderate
parts of the party so I think summer is
using his influence is is um the way
he's surging in the polls to get things
through which Corbin may not have got
through
um around the place definitely the
business companies are there businesses
is there The Cardigans have gone the
suits are back it's like new
neighborhood 96. it's Steve when Steve
was there um in those days I mean it
really is you can almost energize and
feel they can smell Power by the way a
year ago Boris Johnson bestowed
everything below him he had been people
saying he'd be in charge for 10 years A
year later it's all gone a year is a
long time in politics but it's great for
labor now Christopher hope Steve
Richards thank you both very much indeed
thank you